Give me less than 2 minutes and I'm
going to explain how this guy, Alex
Hormozi, uses dead simple copywriting to
sell over a million copies of his book.
Now, expert copywriters are not
impressed with Alex Hormozi, but let me
show you what he's doing really, really
well that people are not catching. This
is a great secret. So, let's read one of
his bullets. The easiest way to get
another five customers tomorrow. That
bullet is not sexy in its writing, but
it's incredibly sexy in its idea.
Alex spends an enormous amount of time
on the big idea of each bullet. He's
trying to find the biggest benefit
possible and put it in an almost
unrealistic fashion. Just stretch it
just enough. He You notice he doesn't
say, "Get you another 50 customers
tomorrow." because that would be too
much of a stretch. But, he doesn't say,
"Get you another customer tomorrow."
That's too small of a promise. So, he's
stretching the promise just enough to
make the big idea worth it.